you
right now I'm enjoying thinking about
what we'll see at the Large Hadron
Collider what is it that they could find
that they're not looking for yet you
know making sure that this you know it's
what we have making sure it does as much
as I can also thinking about what we can
see in in Dark Matter experiments making
sure again that we've considered all the
possibilities and we've both for how to
search and what could be out there and
make sure that we can look for that
other candidates for dark matter you
know what could it be so that's right
now I'm thinking really because we are
in this era where these experiments are
turning on so it's important to really
make sure that we use them for all
they're worth
well right now I'm interested in art and
music I wrote a libretto for a small
what we call projective opera which was
kind of a different kind of way to
communicate ideas to a public it's not a
linear story where we're explaining
things but just to communicate why we
care about exploration and discovery for
me it was just a really interesting
experience to see what it's like to do
something connected with performance it
was performed at the Pompidou Center is
performed in the Opera House in
Barcelona and that was a very exciting
and interesting thing for me I think
right now it's also a little bit
interesting to follow what's going on
with the economy what's going on with
various political things and by fun I
mean kind of disturbing sometimes but I
think there's a lot of interesting
questions that are lurking there that
are fun to think about